and mike and rodney and happy halftime
guys the season
is halfway done i mean some folks didn't
think we'd be playing football in
november and we've gotten this far which
is a full credit to everybody behind the
scenes and the players and coaches too
are making a bunch of sacrifices and we
keep diving into what's going on in on
the field and mike floyer i'll let you
hit this off because san francisco green
bay is the thursday night game green bay
covent impacted in a couple of places
but first to san francisco the 49ers the
nfc champs jimmy garoppolo out for a
stretch now george kittle out for a
stretch all of a sudden in a difficult
division this is looking like a very
uphill climb for the champs of the nfc
to get back in the tournament
well it absolutely is and to throw on
top of that pile mike the 49ers are shut
down on wednesday because they have a
covet 19 positive result coming from
tuesday when they had a full work day
which means there would be potential
close contacts with kendrick born
reportedly the guy who tested positive
there may be other players who suddenly
are unavailable for thursday night's
game if that game even happens so just
another hardship for the 49ers who can't
catch a break this year whether it's
injuries now covet 19 not having key
players and still somehow four and four
tony rodney what is it about trying to
repeat in the nfc get back to the super
bowl when you lose it
it is tough it's tough to repeat if you
win it but if you lose it then you've
got that disappointment on top of that
you have a feel do we need to make
changes do we just stick with what we've
done
everybody's still gunning for you you
get the tough schedules uh it becomes
really really difficult and uh i never
had to to face it you know losing a
super bowl but even when you win one
it's a difficult year that next year
yeah and a good thing for kyle shanahan
he's gone through this early
in the season and he knows how to deal
with it he has a lot of confidence in
his guys the the younger guys had an
opportunity to come and get that
valuable playing experience
so i mean who's who's been better this
year at dealing with injuries and
adversity than kyle shanahan so um we
just got to sit back and wait but the
best thing for them to do is continue to
try to run the football try to stop the
run play good defense create turnovers
and um just just try to do something
positive that help that offense out
i started to mention that earlier i
talked to john lynch after week three
and he said kyle shanahan had done a
phenomenal job of not letting the guys
have excuses of saying you know this is
who we've got we're still going to do
what we do we're still going to win and
building that into
what the players were thinking now this
is a severe test now you lose probably
your best player on offense you lose
your quarterback you've still got guys
like
debo samuel who aren't 100 yet so kyle's
going to be tested but i think john
really was just really praising kyle for
that mindset of we're not going to have
excuses
guys they lost the front end of the
season on the defensive side boza as
well as others rodney the green bay is
on the other side of this game if it
happens on thursday night and let's talk
about the nfc north here for a second
because green bay looked good early on
chicago had moments where they although
the record was really good people
questioned it but they were still
sitting there as a five win team now
after you've watched a couple of weeks
of those teams not play as well
what is your concern level with both
green bay and chicago the teams at the
top of the nfc north
i'm going to focus on green bay we've
talked enough about chicago and my
biggest focus and i got a chance to go
back this morning when i woke up and
watch that film and it was the defense
and the thing that really was disturbing
with all that talent that they got all
the money that they invested on
defensive side those guys didn't give
great effort and you see um preston
smith he's getting blocked by irv
irv smith a a pass receiving tight end
he's not getting off any blocks nose
tackle
kenny smith he's getting double team
he's getting blown off the ball the
safeties can't tackle it was just really
disturbing if you guys get a chance go
back and watch just watch the effort
level of the defense it's it almost
seems like coach at times they sit back
and they know they have an explosive
offense and they wait on aaron rodgers
and to get up by two or three touchdowns
and these guys on defense they're not
focused on stopping the run they want
sacks they want to get after the
quarterback and to me you got to stop
the run first in order to put yourself
in a position to set up you know your
ability to rush the passer and get those
sacks coach
well they've been fortunate because
they've been ahead so much and that has
allowed them just to play past defense
well you're going to get in big games
you're going to play against good teams
you aren't going to be ahead and you are
going to have to stop the run and they
have not done that real real well then
you flip over to chicago their problems
are on the other side of the ball their
offense has not been consistent at all
and
you know you might have a good record in
the division and you might be okay
you're not going to be successful in the
playoffs being a one-dimensional team
chicago's got to get their offense
playing better green bay's got to get
their defense playing better
and the thing that was alarming about
green bay aaron rodgers said after the
game that the team lacked energy and he
said that in the past and he doesn't say
anything accidentally and i just wonder
who it is that's supposed to supply that
impetus that kick that motivation so
guys have energy who's supposed to be
paying attention
prior to the game in the locker room on
the field wherever to turn that around
if that's happening and that's alarming
if that's something that we're going to
see from the packers especially because
they've lost two out of the last three
and they didn't have a lot of energy
when they lost in tampa bay a few weeks
ago
hold on hold on mike hold on it's the
leader it's those guys in the locker
room man you can't i can't sit here and
expect coach dungey to pump me up to go
out on the football field and go play it
comes from within you know they know
what position they're in they know that
they have a really good team but they're
not good enough just to show up they got
to make sure that they're completely
into it that they bring full effort all
the time so i look at the smith brothers
you paid them a heck of a whole lot of
money adrian amos the free safety i look
at all these guys you got veteran guys
on that on kenny clark you paid him a
lot of money and you have to expect
these guys to come out and play every
single week so mike flora i would tell
you the veterans in that locker room
that's who you expect to come out and
speak up and bring that energy every
week
and let me ask this question as a guy
who has become a full-fledged member of
the aaron rodgers fan club this year
what's his role
even if it's a defensive issue is it his
role
like peyton manning would do and tom
brady would do
i promise you i promise you you would
not get that quote from
uh the colts when i was there we didn't
have energy peyton manning would not
allow that uh and rodney i'm sure tom
was the same way
yeah but but
but the way we looked at it is tom you
take care of the offense we're gonna
handle the defense coach you handle the
special teams you know what i mean so
it's one of those things where you know
aaron rodgers a lot of times you listen
to what he says and a lot of times
there's there's hidden messages there's
a level of sarcasm and things like that
but if i was on the green bay packers i
said aaron you don't have to talk about
the defense i'll make sure that the
defense brings energy you just make sure
that the offense steps up and brings the
same energy
one last green bay point mike were you
surprised they didn't pull the trigger
on the trade for fuller from houston
i wasn't surprised because you're taking
on the remainder of an eight figure
salary for a guy who's had plenty of
injuries and you know you're you're
basically trying to change a tire on a
moving car when you pick up a receiver
and jam him into a new offense look at
what happened last year now emmanuel
sanders helped the 49ers but they gave
up a third round pick he walked away in
free agency the patriots gave up a
second round for muhammad sunu that
didn't work out i don't know what the
texans were looking for for will fuller
but the market if it was set last year
maybe they wanted i i can't imagine they
want a first round pick for him but i i
wasn't surprised they didn't do it
because
and at another level too you're kind of
acknowledging if you make the play for
fuller that maybe you should have used
some of your draft assets on a receiver
back in april and not not be playing
this game to try to make your receiving
core better on the fly i think that
probably was another reason why the
packers hesitated
and the thing people don't understand
it isn't like baseball you just come in
and play second base or you come in and
play right field you got to develop a
chemistry with aaron rodgers how long is
that going to take for will fuller so
maybe you're hoping that hey by the time
we get to the playoffs he's ready to go
uh i just think that's a lot to ask a
second or third round pick and then the
guy might not even be there next year
and if if you're the packers why would
you go after a guy that has a history of
injuries a history of not being on a
football field i don't get it i mean if
i'm gonna target a guy i'm gonna target
a guy maybe like allen robinson from the
chicago bears i know he's in the same
division but i'm not gonna target a guy
that i know he's explosive i know he's
fast and he can do some things but you
got to cross your fingers every week to
see if this guy has a poor hamstring or
groin or something like that i wouldn't
touch will filler if i was a team
so
there you have receiver issues in the
depth of the veterans there new orleans
has gone a couple of weeks guys here
without emanuel sanders who mike just
mentioned michael thomas has played one
game guy caught 149 balls last year has
barely been a part of it yet here are
the saints at the top of the division
and on sunday night football we'll have
drew brees and tom brady of the saints
and the buccaneers uh top line thought
on that game rodney i'll get you uh in
here first
well just some of the match-ups you got
uh malcolm jenkins versus gronk i think
that's going to be very interesting you
got these fast athletic linebackers of
the tampa bay buccaneers and defending
alvin kamara and open space drew brees
you know how is he going to deal with
tampa bay and the pressure and all the
different things so for me i'm looking
at all the different matchups across the
board i think it's going to be great
coach
yeah and i look at what
the saints have been able to do and it's
amazing
they have they played really well that
first game against tampa they had all
their weaponry there they haven't had it
since and they're still winning and
they've got to feel like boy if we can
get michael thomas and emmanuel sanders
back we're going to reach another level
but they're going to need that against
tampa they're not going to beat tampa if
they don't have all their machinery in
place
i was intrigued by mike evans comments
to lisa salters of espn after the monday
night win over the giants he said that
antonio brown hopefully will take away
some of the double teams from mike evans
which concedes at a certain level that
maybe antonio brown is the better
receiver that would attract that
attention away from evans but evans
hasn't done much this year not nearly as
much as i thought he would do with a
quarterback like tom brady but if you
put brown on the field with evans and
gronk who's coming along what are the
saints going to do to slow down that
offense and it may end up being a 41-38
shootout whoever has the ball last wins
hey mike so floria are you are you
thinking so you're automatically
assuming that antonio brown is going to
be on the level that he was a couple
years ago
yes
yes and and i don't know
tom brady tom brady didn't engineer this
whole thing roddy just because he likes
the guy tom brady knows what he's
dealing with he saw it for a couple of
weeks last year in new england and he
hasn't let go of it because i think he
saw an antonio brown something that
maybe he hasn't seen since randy moss
i i know that and all i'm saying is you
know a guy hasn't played football and
he's not going to be looked at as coming
in and have to be the number one one guy
i just think it's going to take some
time coach i mean you know better than
me you've coached you know some of the
greatest wide receivers ever play i
think i just think it's going to take a
little time for him to come in learn the
offense get acclimated and know where
his fit is we saw rob gronkowski and we
saw them struggle earlier with some
continuity because they didn't have the
training camp so i don't think antonio
brown is just going to come in right
away and just be successful because he's
tom tom's teammate
yeah as you guys know i live in tampa
and when tom came a ton of hype oh our
offense is going to be great and we're
going to be on fire and you had the
covet situation and he's taken all those
receivers to berkeley high school and
they're working out every single day but
it's not the same thing and we went four
or five weeks oh as tom brady lost it
has gronk lost it he doesn't seem to
have chemistry with mike evans they're
misfiring what's happening well now it
looks pretty good it looks very good as
a matter of fact but i think antonio is
going to have that same situation hey
yeah i run routes and i may be fast and
i may be able to run 4-3 today but i
haven't run these routes with tom brady
he doesn't know how i'm gonna come out
the break when i get jammed when the
guys uh when i read cover two how am i
gonna break this off where am i gonna go
and that to me is what has always made
tom great that anticipation that timing
that's going to have to develop
and that's coming from one of the
greatest coaches of all time thank you
coach
god godwin evans he says that when he
agrees with you coach you notice that
exactly exactly
[Laughter]
they can line up on the field if antonio
brown works out will be such a problem
and then by the way you get spread out
you take gronk you detach them you go
with the four wides which you could when
godwin evans are healthy miller and
antonio brown right and then you have a
light box for leonard fournette and go
deal with that and pound your head into
that they they could tony have as many
options as anybody going into the second
half of the year
if antonio brown plays well and they do
develop that chemistry the only way
you're going to be able to handle them
is to be able to create tremendous
pressure with a four-man rush if you
can't pressure with four men if you have
to blitz and cover all those guys
one-on-one tom is gonna pick that apart
if you can't pressure and you say well
i'm just gonna cover and tom we've seen
him just be just precise up and down the
field so it's going to be a team that
can rush with four guys and create
pressure and still mix the coverages and
there aren't many many of those teams
out there
good
good good rod no i was just i was just
sitting here thinking like are we
overrating tampa bay i mean we get so
caught up and then you dated with like
all the weapons that they have but are
we truly overrating them because you saw
him against chicago we saw some
weaknesses there we saw him against the
giants and it just depends on how you
look at it well they overcame this they
overcame that to win or sometimes they
play down to the level of competition so
but i look at once again i know tom
brady i've been knowing tom brady for 17
years and i've been watching him play
for 17 years and once again when you
make him uncomfortable you're right
coach if you are able to rush him with
four guys and make him uncomfortable tom
turns into a completely different
quarterback so i'm really excited to see
if he can handle pressure from from the
front four that you were talking about
so rodney i'll challenge your point with
this other than seattle who else in the
nfc would you be willing to wager a
milkshake on
um
saint seattle
um
and i don't mean that to challenge you
yeah i don't mean that to challenge you
i'm just elevating the point here there
are not complete teams right now right
this is an odd year it's a different
year so
you stop and you look at it and these
two these may be along with seattle the
three best teams in the nfc built now
for the second half they've survived the
first part of this they're in position
to do that they have a chance to
continue to ascend and get better and
there's a big if with antonio brown i
understand that so i i hear your point i
just think that all of a sudden the
bucks have elevated themselves because
they're six and two into this level of
conversation
mike they're six and two but they still
have eight more games to go and the
biggest deal dealing with the bucks is
their health that was one of the reasons
when and when they went out and got
antonio brown coach and we did this show
the last thing i said is they're getting
depth at the wide receiver spot because
those wide receivers are always injured
now gronk has been great the first eight
games of the season because he's been
healthy
i don't know if i can count on gronk to
be healthy the next eight weeks of the
season the next two months of the season
then you have playoffs and all those
different things so
i
i don't know how much i would bet that
these guys stay healthy and that's a big
part of if they're going to have success
and not mike florio yeah
i think that applies to every team
though but but the buccaneers may be
more susceptible to it than others i'll
agree with you there because of the
history of the injuries can they get
through the next eight games and ride
into january with a full complement of
healthy guys
we'll see and an injury not many people
are talking about is vita veya
um to me that's made a huge difference
they were stuffing the run getting
everybody in second and ten second and
nine and then todd bowles can dial up
all of these intricate blitzes well now
if you're able to run the ball on first
down and make five yards and you're
throwing in in running situations and
throwing against base defense the giants
show that was different
daniel jones if he could have hit some
some plays they had a 35 or 40 point
game out there and a lot of it goes back
to tampa not being the stout against the
run now
intent high scoring game and
with respect with respect to the great
denny green rodney i wasn't trying to
crown him not at this point but i think
we kind of just we're just kind of
pivoting to what we're going to look at
here in the second half of the season uh
guys that what one last one here just a
quick lap around on this you know you
look at games and how the week lays out
seattle going to buffalo intriguing game
that'll be fun to watch buffalo has come
back a little bit in our eyes seattle
continues to play well they travel east
they have at least well pittsburgh
dallas was that featured game man that's
going to be great in november and we
know what dallas's deal is and we know
what pittsburgh's deal is so i'm going
to ask you for one thought on this game
miami at arizona which all of a sudden
has become tony a very intriguing game
in part because of the quarterbacks on
the marquee but the teams have been
performing at a pretty good level the
first half of the season on both sides
of this one
they really have young aggressive team
and watch brian flores in that miami
defense kyler murray has been running
around scrambling moving around getting
the ball to different people watch brian
flores come after him with a lot of
different blitzes like he did last week
and kyla murray is going to have to
handle the pressure and we'll see what
happens
yeah for me i'm looking at um tour and
just seeing if they're going to allow
him to maybe
open up a little bit more i mean last
last week he didn't have to do very much
he had i think through one touchdown
pass um his defense played outstanding
but will they just
be conservative patient with him or will
they allow him to kind of open up the
offense and the second thing i'm looking
for is too is when he gets hit you know
just how his feeling is once he gets hit
like last week he got hit he kind of
jumped up and shook off his shoulders
and it felt good that he didn't get
injured again so that should build some
confidence as well i'll tell you what my
thought is that the dolphins are going
to realize pretty quickly there's a
fundamental difference between jared
goff and kyler murray i think murray is
one of the most exciting players i've
ever seen between the speed the agility
and the awareness he never gets hit
squarely he almost never gets hit at all
he'll slide sideways when he sees
trouble coming he he he never gives in
to that temptation to take on a
defensive back because he's smart enough
to know he would lose but the way he
darts through traffic
i don't know that the dolphins are going
to be able to handle him and and that's
why i think the cardinals given that
they've beaten the seahawks and they get
to play him again i think the cardinals
are a team we need to take seriously as
a potential nfc west champion if they
can take care of the games like this one
where hey if they could beat the
seahawks they should be able to hold
their own against the dolphins
just remember mike they lost to the
lions
that well i know i know and they
shouldn't have and they lost to the
panthers and they shouldn't have so
maybe they learned from that
i mean look the the the lion set a tone
for the big story of the week is that
you can have a big lead in michigan and
things can change on that note
i'm just reporting facts it's it's just
the lions continue to get leads we sit
in the viewing room what do i say tony
every week what time will the lions have
a double double-digit lead we'll set the
over under at 1 30. have a great week
everybody we'll see you this uh sunday
football night in america at 7 eastern
on nbc
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports